this week on the ketchup we are giving
things the multiverse treatment because
trying to figure out what's gonna happen
in the next doctor strange film has been
maddening and then we're gonna head back
in time to a galaxy far far away as part
of our month-long celebration of
everyone's second favorite pop culture
holiday may the fourth the first of
course is 311 day which celebrates the
band 311 every march 11th you're welcome
and we're gonna do that with the rotten
tomatoes show countdown breaking down
the best star wars moments and we're
also celebrating asian american and
pacific islander heritage month with a
look at asian american milestone films
via our show rt essentials plus we're
gonna catch up with the cast of barry as
the highly anticipated third season has
finally arrived i mean this is gonna be
really fun my friend so sit back relax
kick back because with all of that it is
now time for the ketchup
[Music]
welcome to the ketchup your destination
for the latest news in the world of
movies and tv straight from rotten
tomatoes and don't forget we've also got
recommendations for what to watch coming
your way because doing the constant
scroll to try and find something to
watch can be an absolute weekend night
killer and fun sucker and candlelight
blower i mean you get the idea
the freight of the multiverse
depends on us
as we get closer to the may 6 release of
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness it has got most of us wondering
will it be a horror film how many
multiverses will there be and so many
other questions luckily it is my job to
bring you everything we know about the
mcu phase four film right now on the
ketchup so the first thing we can look
at is the potential story of this very
long awaited sequel thanks for nothing
covid starting with avengers end game in
2019 when it became clear that
alternative versions of the mcu would be
a thing in phase four and when marvel
pres kevin feige started talking about
this movie a few years ago at comic con
and d23 he said that it would pull
together various story threads from
around the mcu and man i don't know if
he has a crystal ball or what but based
on what we've seen thus far in phase
four with titles like one division loki
and spider-man no way home their use of
the multiverses clearly matches what
this doctor strange film has in its
title and its trailers
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
speaking of the trailers from what we've
seen so far the plot appears to involve
a breakdown of the multiverse in the
wake of what benedict cumberbatch's
steven strange did in no way home
and obviously it's hard to predict what
the multiverses will bring but we can
look at what we know about the cast to
help get an idea and that includes most
of our friends from the first who are
all returning so why not start at the
top with benedict i mean he's clearly
going through some stuff did you see the
part in the trailer where his face is
like breaking into different squares i
mean that can't be good and along with
what happened in no way home there's
also the potential lingering effects of
the whole snap and blip that happened in
phase three and lucky for us we get to
see cumberbatch and others also play
variants of their characters as well
hello three-eyed dark doctor strange
okay
we're also gonna get to see rachel
mcadams return as dr christine palmer
and as variants of christine now she was
the good doctor's love interest in the
first film but we see her in the trailer
getting ready to marry someone else it's
rumored pretty hard that tom hiddleston
will also grace us with his presence as
loki which makes sense and clearly
elizabeth olsen will join the fun as
wanda maximoff and the scarlet witch as
in they are two different people
now the visuals seem to fit the chaos
that catherine hans agatha harkness
predicted in wanda vision about wanda's
journey to becoming scarlet witch i mean
guys it was hagatha all along i had to
sorry and if you quote star trek the
next generation a lot like i do it is
important to look at the return of
patrick stewart to marvel aka charles
xavier from the x-men movies whose voice
is clearly heard in one of the trailers
so does this mean that we're finally
gonna get mutants in the mcu the big
x-men franchise and mcu crossover who
knows i mean that's the beauty of
multiverses he could be a very different
variant of xavier from the one that we
know or it could just be a whole new
character all together i mean patrick
stewart has got range shakespearean
range at that we should tell him the
truth
all jokes about me allegedly liking star
trek aside what i'm actually most pumped
for is the live-action debut of a new
character america chavez she is played
by sochi gomez in this film and i am a
major fan of her ever since watching the
babysitter's club on netflix and at
least in the comics america chavez is
capable of jumping around the multiverse
under her own power so this all seems
like a great fit and i cannot wait which
brings us to the film's director sam
raimi who stepped in after the first
film's director scott derrickson left
the project along with his head writer
after a disagreement in the direction of
the story now derekson's more
horror-centric resume was reason to
believe the rumor is that this film
could definitely go the horror route but
sam raimi who said that he was done with
superhero movies after spider-man 3 in
2007 has hinted that horror is still
very much involved and does have the
chops to pull it off along with whatever
else the multiverse throws at us
especially since he's working with
low-key head writer michael waldron
you're taking me somewhere to kill me
no i'm taking you someplace to talk
well i don't like to talk
but you do like to lie which you just
did
because we both know you love to talk
all right my friends that is what we
know of course you can find more
rottentomatoes.com and don't forget to
hit us up on social media and tell us
what you think is gonna happen and like
i said earlier we take may the fourth
pretty seriously around here which is
why one day of celebrating is just not
enough we're gonna do it the whole month
and we're doing it on pretty much all of
our shows here at rotten tomatoes so
let's take a quick peek at one of those
on this week's rt highlights starting
with countdown which is bringing us the
best star wars moments number four duel
of the fates star wars episode 1 the
phantom menace
the final act of the phantom menace has
everything you need in a star wars movie
but the standout by far is a three-way
lightsaber fight between qui-gon jinn
obi-wan and darth maul wielding his dual
lightsaber maul shows his true skills
and despite battling for a good amount
of time qui-gon meets his demise obi-wan
eventually avenges qui-gon but as we
learned later in the clone wars maul
survived the attack this sequence is
awesome but what makes it truly amazing
is john williams's epic score duel of
the fates we love the fight sequence but
the music makes it far more memorable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number three battle of yavin star wars
episode 4 a new hope
in the final act of the original star
wars movie we see the rebels in a
full-out attack against the empire the
death star and eventually darth vader so
much happens during this final battle
x-wings y-wings tie fighters luke learns
to trust his feelings vader's skills as
a pilot han returning the death star
blowing up it is just all too good it's
an exciting ending to a wonderful movie
and shows the rebels getting a big win
over the empire
[Music]
ignition
[Music]
i have you now
what
[Music]
look out
[Music]
you're all clear kid now let's swallow
[Music]
number two luke saves the day the
mandalorian
the first season of the mandalorian
showed us how well a live-action star
wars tv show could do but season two
stepped up its game while there are many
great moments in the season it's the
final episode chapter 16 the rescue that
really caught us by surprise our heroes
are pinned down by dark troopers and all
hope seems to be lost but suddenly an
x-wing arrives at first it's confusing
who is that and then suddenly it clicks
could it be there's no way
and that is when luke skywalker appears
and demolishes the dark troopers seeing
a post return of the jedi luke skywalker
was so surprising it's still hard to
believe we got such an iconic sequence
luke cuts through the dark troopers like
nothing and to top it off he recruits
grogu to be part of his new jedi academy
it is an unbelievable action sequence
followed by a heartfelt moment to end
the second season of the mandalorian
[Music]
my jedi
[Music]
[Music]
oh wow
so weird that voice sounds so familiar
okay so i know we're all gonna need some
more of that countdown especially to
find out what is number one so be sure
to check out countdown new episodes air
every week and i host it and for more
lists and scores be sure to check out
next up we are going to shift our
celebrating from r2d2 and c3po to aapi
as in asian american and pacific
islander heritage month and one way we
are doing that here around tomatoes this
month is by taking a deep dive into some
of the milestone films made by and
featuring some of the most talented and
influential asian american filmmakers
and actors in hollywood this is rt
essentials
this whole time
you were right here
when dad died
you know ma and i could have really used
your help i know i know blooming into
the next spot on this list is 2019's
musical drama yellow rose with filipino
american film director diane paragus at
the helm this film follows rose played
by eva noblazada a filipina illegal
immigrant teenager who has dreams of
leaving her small town in texas to
become a country music singer but when
her mother played by princess penzalen
is detained by immigration rose is
forced to flee the scene and she embarks
on a journey of self-discovery while
searching for a new home in the honky
tonk world of austin texas the film
which dianne peragas had been working on
since 2004 also stars leia salonga and
dale watson and premiered at the los
angeles asian pacific film festival in
may of 2019. it went on to win 13 film
festival awards mostly in recognition
for august directing and the
performances by nooglazada and salonga
also receiving a lot of love was the
soundtrack for this musical film which
features singing from paragus as well as
noblezada salanga and dale watson ones
and left they're a little cheaper yeah
i like your notebook oh thanks
towns is like my spirit god
it's like dead flowers yeah
and after delay thanks to covet 19 the
film eventually hit theaters in october
of 2020 becoming one of the first
filipino-american films to be released
by a major hollywood studio for
theatrical release and with a certified
fresh score on the tomato meter the
response from critics was positive like
the ap's jake coyle who said that this
movie sings an affecting sorrowful and
defiant song where dreams collide with a
cruel reality and the overall consensus
from critics called yellow rose a coming
of age story with a timely twist
offering a fresh and sweetly rewarding
perspective on the immigrant experience
saving face
that you
we've been saving the next spot on our
list of asian american milestones for
this film 2004's saving face this
romantic dramedy marked the first
hollywood movie centered around chinese
americans since the joy luck club from
over a decade earlier in 1993 and it was
written and directed by alice wu in her
feature length debut
the film focuses on wilhemina or will
played by michelle krushick a young
chinese-american surgeon who is gay but
not out to her widowed mother or her
very traditional grandparents but the
tables are turned when will finds out
that her 48 year old mother is actually
pregnant and also moving in this puts a
little bit of a strain on will's
relationship with the openly gay vivien
played by lynne chen alice wu originally
began writing this story as a novel
inspired by her own experience coming
out as gay to her middle-aged mother it
eventually turned into a script and had
interest around hollywood but wu said
some studios wanted it to more closely
resemble films like my big fat greek
wedding or at least make some characters
white so they could add a big star like
scarlett johansson but wu didn't budge
and also made sure that the mandarin
dialogue lesbian romance and her
involvement both as writer and director
were non-negotiable
the script eventually caught the
attention of will smith and james
lasseter's overbrook entertainment who
produced the project and with a minimal
budget the film borrowed a helicopter
that was being used for smith's movie
hitch so they could shoot landscape
shots of new york and the certified
fresh saving face went on to be a hit
with both fans and critics with a
consensus from the latter saying that
it's a charming tale of a love affair
that overcomes cultural taboos i mean
who knew just how essential that show
was gonna be to our day i just love
saying the word essential but for the
rest of that list and more deep dives
into all kinds of topics be sure to
check out more rt essentials moving on
now to some essential television one of
the best half hour dramedies from the
past few years is finally returning for
a third season after an extended break i
mean we've waited so long and i am
talking about hbo's barry
co-created by alec berg and bill hader
and starring hater this series is about
a midwest hitman who ends up in la and
involved in the local theater scene and
we actually got a chance to sit down
with much of the outstanding ensemble
cast in the show to see what we can
expect from season three let's take a
look
well first of all thank you so much for
giving us season three it's absolutely
amazing uh i have to say i've seen it
but for the folks who haven't yet the
trailer let's just say previews that
barry's having a rough go of it and
really having a hard time balancing so
what was it like jumping into the chaos
of where we left him in season two for
season three you know it's a different
kind of it's a tough season you know it
was a tough tough thing to kind of
figure her out um
but you know he he's definitely uh
i don't know his back is against the
wall this season
i don't know how else to say it
you know he's really
i you don't think things could get worse
but they do and it's kind of his you
know it's his fault so
yeah i heard you say in an interview
it's going to be interesting to see if
fans are going to be able to stick with
barry as he goes through this season
and i know it's sort of like around the
season theme is this idea of like if
what you do
is also the thing that destroys you is
what the thing that you're good at i
know like you can't climb up your own
stuff for that i i do have to say like
what do you think themes are going to
play out on that and how therapeutic was
it to kind of like write that through a
season of television
yeah i mean i never try to
the yeah doing this stuff is never a
therapy for me in any way hopefully
people don't watch the show especially
some of the scenes and think oh he's
working something out because they'll be
like oh he's a monster
um
it's you know definitely these themes of
redemption and and can you you know
forgiveness is something that has to be
earned
and then is that even is forgiveness
even a thing you know and and i don't
really know the answer to these things
and that's that's why it's fun to create
stuff because you can kind of ask
yourself these questions and
try to
figure it out but
this season
he's definitely it's he's definitely in
a darker place uh than he has been the
first two seasons and that's really
saying something so i don't i don't know
if uh
yeah we might be scared it's still a
comedy right
it's still funny yeah i actually feel
like to see this season has some of the
funniest stuff we've ever done it gets
really silly in some parts but yeah it
is a it is it's rough
okay well i hope somebody that's
bringing
maybe a little bit of light to it i
can't think of anything less from him
henry winkler but you know i think he
said that barry's going into the season
knowing that
gene likely saved his life and just that
dynamic between the two talk about you
know
you and henry working that out and what
you wanted their relationship to be in
cv3
well their relationships are very
complicated because barry kind of sees
him as yeah the guy that
saved his life and and all these things
and then uh and then the end of season
two from barry's point of view is that
you know kusino
uh saw janus's you know uh body and all
this stuff and berries
you know uh they were both
arrested and it was you know and all
this stuff and it was terrible and you
know he kind of goes away uh
kind of
into
hiding in a way barry does you know kind
of emotionally and
and and um
and cousnow unbeknownst to barry uh
knows where we pick up and so
it was kind of going like what we like
to do every season we like to write
ourselves into a corner and go
well let's see what happens
yeah and i've heard you've already
written yourself into a corner for
season four but you've already mapped it
out are you still committed to ten
episodes directing and are you crazy
oh yeah yeah i'm crazy
i am so stoked for that show to be back
and if you haven't seen it now is the
time to tune in my friends you can catch
it on hbo max and for more cast
interviews from all your favorite movies
and tv shows check out
rottentomatoes.com and if you are
anything like me you've probably run
into a little problem called so many
shows so little time so to help you read
through the many many options of what to
watch and prioritize just a little bit
i'm gonna let you know what i have been
really into lately starting with
severance on apple tv plus now i'm sure
at this point you've heard of severance
and if you haven't you are in luck this
show is must-watch television it is so
gripping that i was watching episodes on
my phone in the middle of the workday
with headphones on like a middle
schooler in the back of a classroom it
stars adam scott in a rare lead role who
is great and juggernauts like patricia
arquette christopher walken and john
tuturo who i believe is america's best
kept secret i mean please just put him
in everything and i'm not even gonna
tell you what it's about just go watch
it it is straight up appointment viewing
television and my favorite show on tv
right now also the finale will blow your
mind i mean i haven't been this excited
about a show since succession season one
now i always recommend things on tv but
i want to implore you to head to the
theater to go see a24s everything
everywhere all at once it's another one
i'm hesitant to tell you too much about
but i can tell you that it is unlike
anything i have ever seen and i think
it's gonna get some academy award
nominations and maybe give michelle yo
her first oscar you will leave
questioning everything about life in a
good way and it is an emotional
rollercoaster from start to finish also
there's great fight and action sequences
and jamie lee curtis is scarier and
better than ever in it
okay so last i was a huge fan of bridger
10 season 2 on netflix even more so than
season 1 and i think most people agree
considering the fact that it became
netflix's most watched english series
language debut now i loved it because i
was really worried going in that i was
gonna miss the characters from season
one since this season the focus was
really on the vi counts love story but
the storytelling was so compelling and
juicy for lack of a better word that i
was sold i mean two sisters both liking
the same guy and you add in some
fabulous fashion and lady whistle down
who's basically the show's gossip girl i
mean you've got all the escapism you
need and those are all my
recommendations my friends that does it
for this latest episode of the ketchup i
hope you enjoyed it be sure to stay
tuned to the ron tomatoes channel for
more of your favorite movies and tv and
for scores recommendations and more be
sure to check out rottentomatoes.com i'm
nasa perez and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you